alternative films often challenged the
language of film making personal
expression and aesthetic exploration
their primary concerns and while the
filmmakers and all the other categories
are anxiously awaiting this evening to
see which award they will receive in
their respective categories one
filmmaker has been much more relaxed
that's because Academy voters selected
only one film this year to represent
alternative filmmaking and so taking
home the gold is filmmaker Amanda Tassie
with her entry titled the reality clock
this is actually one of my favorites
that I saw for this evening made very
near here at the University of Southern
California her film takes a unique look
at an elderly watchmakers struggle with
the early stages of dementia and its
effects on his identity and sense of
time I can't see one of you it's an
interesting experience so first I would
like to thank the academy there you are
thank you for their incredible
generosity this is the most encouraging
support that I can imagine at this stage
in my career and I want to also thank my
father who was a natural storyteller the
inspiration for this film strangely
dedicated cameraman he even filmed my
birth on super 8 it's kind of awkward
but an interesting experience to see and
a passionate epic multi-part Stephen
King story teller on long road trips
when we weren't listening to the Beastie
Boys license to when he was sick even
though he could barely stand he stood
literally by my side during the initial
shooting of the time-lapse photography
scenes it was a pilgrimage to places we
had lived and this film was inspired by
him though not directly about him I'd
also like to thank my ever nurturing and
supportive mom who
inherited the position of number-one fan
thank you mom and to the individuals who
opened up to me and shared the end part
of their lives with me when I was a
hospice volunteer worker and encountered
many people who had dementia to my
incredibly talented and dedicated crew
quiz Chris Swanson and Dick Kaneshiro
tireless innovative artists and
fabricators Igor nemirovsky super fast
and brilliant music composer Chris
Julian an amazingly professional and
talented sound mixer and sound artist a
voiceover actor j lewis Reed was a
pleasure to work with he completely got
the feeling of the dialogue and
channeled his own life experience into
into the film marco tozzi oly brilliant
actor he cries on cue he also lenders
painstaking process of pixilation tuning
I came an actor into a puppet it's an
awkward experience and he did it
beautifully countless friends who
pitched in for a day or two stereo
mentors and gurus puri Hoberman Eric
Carlin Brian Davis John Christopher and
the LA 3d movie club in the 3d force
you're the people were responsible for
the painstaking process of it of doing
stereo I probably would have done it
without you for better for worse i love
stereo faculty mentors kathy smith eric
hansen rachel johnson steve anderson the
USC division of animation and digital
arts and the i'm at media arts and
practice program the sloan science
foundation for animation grant and the
Annenberg fellowship for paying for
school which is an amazing thing and
most of all I am so happy that some of
you have connected with the film and
fonts and meaning in it to me that is
the greatest honor of all thank you very
much